Our Father in Heaven once again as we
come here and
seek to meditate upon your word Lord and
the counsel you've given us in the
spirit of Prophecy and understand the
biblical basis for this gift
father I just pray again that you would
illuminate our minds help us to
understand what you have in this message
for us today help us to understand what
you want us to understand today what you
want us to learn today and help us Lord
to apply it as you would have it to have
us apply it to our lives
and father I thank you for my restored
Health this morning and I Praise You In
Jesus name amen
well I'm still I I want to tell you
something I've had stomach flu before
and I'm telling you I mean this is just
I'm just praising the Lord today oh
incidentally Ben was talking to me some
of you may have coughs you know I've had
he had a little bit of a cough and one
of the one of the best things you can do
for a cold
you know when you breathe out when you
exhale you don't exhale all the air in
your lungs
one good thing to do is to get out in
fresh air as fresh as you can get out
here in Detroit
and exhale and forcefully exhale all
your air and then take in deep breaths
just do an exchange of that stale air
get it out of your lungs you know Ellen
White says that one of the best forms of
exercise is does anybody know
walking in the fresh air she says early
morning exercise in the open air why
because when you exercise
you expel you expel more of the bad air
you breathe in more of the good air you
got more circulation and of course
you're getting that your blood recharged
okay
she says this would cure coughs colds
and 100 other illnesses
and another thing you can do anybody
know who Dr Burnell Baldwin is
when I went to uh Mission College of
evangelism but Dr Baldwin was there and
he talked to us about something he
called Adventist coffee and I'm not
talking about Roma you want to know what
Adventist coffee is
when you take your shower in the morning
finish with cold
you don't need to do and He will
caffeine you don't caffeine won't do
anything like that culture but that cold
shower also to finish off with cold will
increase your circulatory uh assist your
circulation and that will help you fight
off a lot of stuff just finishing off
if you can bring yourself to do it
huh just a just a just a 20 or 30
seconds for some people it's 10. you
know they're out of the shower but it it
just uh it just anyway
that's not our subject today let's move
on okay I'm going to move through the
rest of these kind of quickly because
you have the note
this one I really like this text in
Proverbs 29 18. number six
a roll of the gift of Prophecy to
provide proper boundaries and guidelines
for the church
let's go to Proverbs 29 and verse 18 and
who wants to read that for me
um hold on hold on hold on
you got to tell me your name again
ah Ezekiel I should have remembered that
name good Bible name a good prophet name
man Ezekiel 29 Proverbs 29 and verse 18.
what version are you reading out of
there you King James okay good now
listen to what hold on a minute before
you do that does anybody have the King
James version
okay
um
Chantal
Chantel could you read that and then I
want Ezekiel to read it now listen to
what it says there and I want you to
catch the difference
29 verse 18.
where there is no vision the people
perish but he that keeps it to law happy
is he okay where there is no vision the
people
perish now listen to how they perish as
the new King James adds a little bit of
an element to this listen to what it
says
well there is no revelation
Street what happens
okay where there is no vision the people
perish where there is no Revelation and
sometimes if you have that some of the
pro your marginal readings will say
prophetic Vision or Revelation where
there is no Revelation the people what
cast off restraint
I'm under grace I can do I can live
however I want to live
right we cast off restraint one of the
purposes of the prophetic vision is to
give us boundaries in our Christian
experience I preached on this in my
church a couple weeks ago let me tell
you something just briefly
one of the things that we catch more
heat on as Seventh-Day Adventists even
amongst our own members is the standards
that we have in our church
because we're so strict have all these
rules all these do's and don'ts you
heard it right
got all these
and so we get a lot of feedback on that
not generally real positive got too many
rules in our church
now
I want you to think something through
for a minute
how many of you are married in here
okay you married people
when you got married
you had some new rules
right
ladies and I hope you follow through
with this
you took down the pictures of the old
boyfriends
hopefully disposed of them someplace
disposed of not stored them
in
right
it wouldn't be a good idea for you would
that strengthen your relationship to
keep those pictures up okay so there's
some things you had to get rid of the
old pictures guys
um
you had to break up with the old
girlfriends
right
yeah
but some of you guys are like
okay
you got to keep an eye on these guys
here David
um but you had certain things that came
in your life you know that you started
you you needed to ask there are certain
things that in your life you changed the
time that maybe as guys that you hung
out with the guys was a little bit less
now and the time you hung out with the
girl was was more you spent some time
together you cleared out more of your
schedules for each and you had some
things that you arranged you had some
boundaries that came into your life that
may not have been there before right you
had some new do's and don'ts
right
I hope you don't complain about those
now why were those do's and don'ts
brought into your life
what was the main purpose for those
things when you become when you enter
into that marriage relationship and now
you you have some things now that you do
that you didn't do before and some
don'ts that you uh you know the taking
down the pictures Etc why do you have
that
ah to do what say that louder
important really to protect an important
relationship
now listen to me
question
if you are not following through with
those new rules guidelines that a
married old person incidentally another
thing that I could throw in there is
that you're not as familiar with people
of the opposite sex anymore right
certain things you do to guard that
relationship right if you're not
following through with those things
do you care much about the relationship
I say no
if you say ah it doesn't matter I'm
still hanging out with the guys whenever
I want to and I'm not gonna I'll come
home and I want to come home and and I'm
going to still keep my picture and my
girlfriends up and and uh I'm gonna do
is that gonna do you care about your
relationship
no not with an attitude like that are
you following me
it's only the people who care about the
relationship
that follow the rules of the
and I want to tell you something this
morning and you mark my words on this a
person who starts to complain about the
do's and don'ts in the church
doesn't have a very good relationship
doesn't care very much about the
relationship because those standards
that we have
as a church are simply boundaries to
protect and preserve the relationship
with Christ
and if a person comes out and says well
I think all that matters is a
relationship with Jesus they're talking
out of two sides of their mouth
because if they really cared about their
relationship with Jesus they would
follow the boundaries that preserve the
relationship are you with me on that
that's what the spirit of Prophecy is
given for one of the roles is to give
boundaries to to and and when the when
the prophecy isn't there when the vision
is not there the people cast off
restraint there's no more restraint
there's no more boundary there's no more
direction to help us to know don't go
this way don't go that way you're going
to go off the path
you follow that does that make sense
okay
um
number seven and I'm not going to look
these up I'm just going to note them for
you have them there on your sheet
to warn of future difficulties
uh you find there are texts there
throughout the Book of Acts where God
had spoken through a prophet
in the early church to warn of something
like when Paul was going to be taken to
go to Jerusalem and agabus the prophet
came and he told him the man who owns
this belt is going to be bound up and
they were God used the gift of Prophecy
to tell some of the hurdles that they
were going to have coming up in their
experiences incidentally agabus never
told Paul not to go did you know that
he just told him what was coming
you know we have counsel that Ellen
White's given that tells us what's ahead
it doesn't she doesn't say you better
stop preaching the message because
you're going to get no but she wants us
to know listen
have you ever been in a situation
where God has brought a trial and you
start to question your faith
you start to question if I'm doing the
right thing if I was doing the right
thing why is all this stuff happening to
me have you ever done that
well that's why God spoke through the
prophets in the scriptures that's why he
spoke through Ellen White to tell a
certain things that would happen so when
you and I are about to doubt and say it
seems like I'm on the wrong path the
Lord says hold on a minute you know this
is exactly what I told you what would
happen oh you know that's right
and so
it warns us the gift of Prophecy God
uses to warn us of future difficulties
and the next one there to encourage and
comfort the church
Romans 15 4 tells us that by patience
and comfort of the scriptures we might
have hope
scriptures are written by the prophets
to encourage and comfort you know people
talk about the writings of Ellen White
and they say man there's all these dudes
and I want to tell you man if you read
in Ellen White's writings there is so
much powerful encouragement in the
writings of Illinois for anybody who's
read them powerful encouragement
and uh
and we'll look at some of those things
as we go and then the last one there to
prove prosper and Preserve God's people
to prosper and preserve God's people
there's something I want to look at here
um of course we started out this section
with Hosea 12 13.
buy a prophet
God LED Israel out of Egypt and by a
prophet he was preserved and I'll tell
you right now if it were not for the
gift of Prophecy this Adventist movement
would have died a long time ago
would have died a long time but the
devil has tried to destroy this movement
more than once
and it's been as people went back and
were clarified in our doctrinal
understandings Etc strengthened in the
work in our missionary work etc by going
to the council that God's given us and
God saved us from numerous
um
crises
in this work incidentally that last note
there tells us that the gift of Prophecy
is the only gift to be included in all
four spiritual gifts lists and you have
the chapters there that list them
and I want to make this one point the
Bible says in Ephesians when we read the
other day God gave some to the apostles
some prophets some evangelists some
pastors some teachers
there's an important distinction between
the prophet
and the Apostle the Evangelist the
pastor and the teacher
the Apostle the Evangelist the pastor
the teacher get their Authority
from the words of the prophets
and the prophets get their Authority
straight from God
sometimes I wish as a pastor Lord
tell me
but God speaks to us through the voice
of prophets doesn't he
and uh and then through the prophet
to the church and that's how he's done
that's his order of things now is
everybody clear on that does anybody
have any questions on what we've covered
so far
are you guys with me
is this making sense to you yes okay it
doesn't do me you know I can get up here
and get excited about text all day long
if you guys are like I don't know what
that guy's saying he's awful enthused
but I know what he's saying doesn't help
any of us so I just want to make sure
that if you have any questions I'm going
to take pauses here and there for for
questions any if in the middle of any
anything that I'm saying just if you
have a question raise your hand let me
know and we'll deal with it okay
that sound fair
what we're going to do is I'm going to
ask for two volunteers
at least two volunteers to pass out some
of the the next handout here
and we're going to look at the tests of
the profit
I don't know where those came from
if you would pass those out
the title on the top of the page is
beware of false prophets
and I'll let them distribute
I know also that some of you are
probably as we're going through some of
these things you're probably thinking
okay we're talking a lot about Bible
prophets and stuff when do we get into
the spirit of Prophecy but we will don't
worry about that but I want us to
understand from a Bible basis how the
gift of Prophecy works
because we've got people who come to us
and say you happen to say you know this
that and the other about a prophet
that's how the Bible tells us about
prophets we're not making anything up
we've not followed any cunningly devised
Fables
so
be yes sir of course
okay
did you hear the quest
you have to convince people that this is
the word of God why don't we just use
that same testing criteria and saying
this is the most current profit yeah
question was why
if if Ellen White is how how did you
wear that again if she's the most
current Prophet she's the most current
prophet and fits the criteria the Bible
test Etc
then why are we so reluctant to share
what Ellen White says
and we'll spend more time on that than
just right now but I'll say this
one reason is that the gift of Prophecy
is primarily given for the church we're
going to see that in this study okay why
because you and I have an opportunity to
test the gift
did you know Ellen White said in her day
that that a belief in her gift was not a
test for church membership
a belief in this gift of Prophecy in the
last day church was because the Bible's
clear on that but she said people coming
to church how do they know I'm a prophet
when they've had no time to test me
so she said they were to be given time
to be tested uh to test rather to test
your gift
you see if I have that paper here
she also said
and and this also went with the leaders
of our church that when people had an
opportunity to test her and then were
found fighting against her
they needed to be labored with and if
they didn't yield they need to be
disfellowshipped some people will quote
you the one half
the only Point she was making is they
need to be given time but you and I
already know that if a person is
fighting against the spirit of Prophecy
we've tested her I've tested the prophet
and I know it's a prophet of God and if
a person doesn't believe in it they've
not they've rejected the truth
but they're to be given time to
investigate yes sir
yes it should more so
and we'll talk about that we'll get into
that but uh I will say again in our
public labors I've got a letter here in
fact I've had somebody tell me once
we shouldn't quote Ellen White in the uh
on sabbaths on the pulpit and I thought
you know if you've got if God gave a
prophet to the church and you can't read
what the prophet wrote in the church
what in the world can you do with it
and so uh but they they brought it from
this statement of Ellen White and I
called incidentally
if you read something that Ellen White
has written
and you get a portion if you know there
are certain things that if you get on
the CD-ROM you still can't find the
whole
context you'll find the little ellipses
you know an ellipsis uh you know what
Ellipsis is
you're like well what was there I want
to get the whole context
if you have a case like that and there
isn't and there are some things that the
whole context wasn't published you call
the white estate tell them you'd like it
tell them what you need it for and
they'll send it to you
that statement that Ellen White gave was
she says this and it's quoted this
little part's quoted and I just want to
read the whole letter
in public labor do not make prominent
and quote that which sister white has
written as authority to sustain your
positions to do this will not increase
faith in the testimonies bring your
evidences clear and plain from the word
of God thus saith the Lord is the
strongest testimony you can possibly
present to the people let none be
educated to look to Sister white but to
the Mighty God who gives instruction to
Sister White
okay now when you read that even that
more carefully which he says you know
I've had people say well you can't you
shouldn't we bring it up Ellen White in
the pulpit
she says in public labor
do not make prominent and quote sister
white as authority to sustain your
positions
use the Bible I don't do an Evangelistic
meeting and say well you you folks know
that Ellen White the prophet in our
church says they've got no reason to
believe in that but they believe the
Bible see you follow so we'll get we'll
get more into that as we go on
tests of the prophetic gift beware of
false prophets Matthew 7 15 somebody
want to read that for me
Matthew 7 15.
who wants to read Matthew 7 15 for me
and your name again was Daniel
man these oh we got all these Prophet
names in here how many of you have
Prophet names we got Ezekiel we got
Daniel
that's it
and your contemporaries
what's a contemporary
all right they were probably at the same
time
Josh well Joshua he's a mighty Captain I
don't know if I'd say necessarily he was
Joshua was the name of a high priest too
but I don't know if there's a prophet
unless the Lord enlightens you and gives
you to chooses you to be a prophet now
then we'd have a prophet Joshua
David was a prophet
so
where is David I just saw David are
there another is there another David
well miss David we know he's a prophet
all right
Let's uh Matthew said now who did I ask
to read again Daniel Daniel Matthew 7
15. now pay attention what he says
Beware of the false prophets to come to
you and keep exploding but in order okay
beware of and as you see they're
highlighted beware of what
he doesn't say beware of what
he doesn't say beware of prophets
you know there are people today who do
not believe there is any Prophet past
the New Testament
did you know that
you know some people even take a test
like text like this and say well
you know that was it all ended with John
the Revelator okay
but Jesus tells them beware of false
prophets and he also talks about it in
Matthew 24 doesn't he false prophets
will come in the last days when he's
given the signs of his coming
now if you were Jesus and you knew there
were going to be no more true Prophets
and you were trying to help your
disciples to understand this and you
were giving signs of your coming what
would you tell them
beware of anybody who claims to be a
prophet because they're not one
right wouldn't that be easier
but he says he doesn't say that he says
beware of false prophets
how are we to determine whether a profit
is a true profit or false prophet first
Thessalonians 5 and verse 19.
who'd like to read for me there first
Thessalonians 5 and 19.
who said that
Ezekiel our other prophet
first Thessalonians 5 19 to 21.
you're you're not there Ezekiel
well so much he failed the test
[Laughter]
okay
4 19-21
but PSI 5 19 to 21. I was like yeah
there's nothing there
now I failed the test I told you I
wasn't a prophet to begin with so
okay
do not
quench the spirit does anybody else have
a different translation that reads
differently
stifle the spirit what does it mean to
quench something
what's the picture that comes to your
mind when you hear quench
water
don't you get the idea of water on a
fire don't quench the spirit
don't put out the spirit's fire I think
the NIV says don't put out the spirit's
fire well how are we going to put out
the spirit's fire look at the next verse
do not what
despise prophecies
what are we to do verse 21
test all things test everything and hold
to what is good and again in first John
4 1
we see the same thing
first John chapter 4 and verse one who
wants to read that
somebody who hasn't read yet
first John 4 1
you're gonna have to tell me your name
again
Ah that's it Angela
Angela first John 4 1.
okay same thing that Paul tells us
essentially test the spirits don't
believe them all put them to the test
what kind of test
well we know that we test everything by
the scripture amen
and there are scripture tests for the
prophet we are going to look at two
types of things in fact I don't know
that I would call this first section
test we're going to look at physical
phenomena
physical phenomena in in essence uh
there are things that the Bible tells us
that happened to a prophet physically
yes sir so just back it up really
quickly
have you ever had somebody quote uh
verse 21 there first Thessalonians 5.
they say yeah I've examined Ellen White
and there are certain parts that I agree
with and I hold back to that but
everything else I think is kind of a
hogwalk yeah
yeah and we're going to get into that a
little bit more and and and I would say
just very simply from that we don't have
any case in the scripture of anybody
being a half prophet
somebody could take well anyway
I'll tell you what something in the uh
in the handout that I'm going to give
you I got to find where I put it again
Warren Johns was the attorney for the
white estate but with the with work with
the white estate
who paid incidentally this this hiring
of Vincent ramek to investigate the uh
plagiarism case was paid with private
funds you know because then somebody
said well the address paid for it and
this that and the other Warren John's
the attorney for one of the attorneys
for our church one of three for this
worldwide church at the time took it
upon himself to make sure to pay
and hire this Law Firm to do this
research but Warren John said something
that I have
ever since people have heard me repeat
it in fact
I just read this the other day and
remembered where I'd I finally remember
where I'd gotten it from he says this
but in the final analysis for those who
choose to believe no proof is necessary
and for those who choose to disbelieve
no proof is possible
you need to hold to that I've had
studies with people before you ever have
a study with somebody and you just think
ah if I could just get that one perfect
text
and you go and you talk to somebody and
they say oh tell them this you go oh
that'd be an excellent one and you go
back and study with them and you show
them that text what happens
if a person doesn't want to believe it
you guys you could give them 150 million
texts it's not going to change them
a lot of times it's not that they tested
Ellen White and a lot of times it's
because they don't want to accept it
and um
I'm not saying it every I'm not going to
say We'll address a little bit more of
that as we go
um
but I'm just saying a lot of times when
people are argumentative like that they
really don't want to know you could you
could show them all kinds of reasons to
believe in the gift of Prophecy and they
won't believe it
I'll tell you this you know what the
best reason for the validity of the gift
of Prophecy is
for me that I'm standing in front of you
today
that's my that's the best reason for me
if you've experienced the power of the
gift of Prophecy in your life you know
that it's of God there's no question
and that's how in in all reality that's
how you're going to test the spirit more
than anything when the apostles said
test the spirits I don't think he's just
talking an intellectual understanding
it's experiential when you go out and
you venture out on the word of the Lord
when the Lord has said something and you
venture your faith out upon that you'll
know
then you'll know it's real
um physical phenomena I'm not going to
spend a whole lot of time on the
physical phenomena I just want to
highlight this for you
these These are types of things that
happen to prophets in their Visions for
example the first one their prophets are
aware of Supernatural communication so
that when a prophet's having a vision
you see you have to understand that
especially in the day when Ellen White
received this gift right after the great
disappointment there was a lot of
sensationalism in the churches
and so people would people would claim
all kinds there are lots of people
claimed to have the gift of Prophecy one
of Ellen White's contemporaries that
claimed to have the gift of Prophecy was
a man by the name of
Joseph Smith who also promoted bigamy
just have all kinds of wives it's no big
deal that's why God wants it to be and
he's got all these crazy ideas and so in
fact that really brought down the whole
idea the concept of a prophet in
people's minds okay
so you've got other people claiming to
have messages from the Lord
so the Lord allowed for certain
evidences
the Lord allowed for certain evidences
and I'll tell you some of these things
we're looking at here in Ellen White's
early experience she had a lot of
physical manifestations that testified
to the fact that her
um Visions were Supernatural
what word did I say
okay does that validate the gift no all
it does is tell you that it's not a
man-made power it's a supernatural power
that in and of itself a physical
manifestation is not going to prove to
you that this is a valid gift of
Prophecy but it will prove that it's not
a person who's who thinks that they've
had they have the gift for prophecy
has anybody here ever met somebody who
thought they had the gift of Prophecy
yeah I'll tell you what there's a lot of
churches today with Prophets
did you know that you know where's
evidence we're like oh you know that's
odd today go to Pentecostal Church man
everybody's a prophet I had a guy tell
we would do a door-to-door work knocked
on the guy's door and he's like yeah we
got a prophet in our church she writes
something to get and what they would do
is they'd write stuff out and have these
stacks of testimonies in the back of the
church and urge the church members to
take them on the way out and read this
was their prophet
and it's I've had people in Evangelistic
meetings come up I had two prophets in
my last Evangelistic meeting
the Lord they were the Lord spoke to
them one clearly told me she was a
prophet and the other alluded to the
fact you know the gentleman alluded to
the fact that he was a prophet
so
you know and why because they have some
Sensational experience so the lord gave
Supernatural evidences that would tell
the people in her day that there's
something to this of course they had to
apply the biblical tests too but it kind
of weeded out all the sensational
uh profits you follow me so far
prophets are aware of their Supernatural
of Supernatural Communication in other
words it isn't just somebody who has a
uh some kind of flight of emotion but
there was a they were there was a clear
communication going on the prophet had
acknowledged when they went into Vision
there was a clear communication between
God and the and the human being
I like this statement in Messenger to
the remnant uh it's an interesting
question I probably would have asked
myself
I myself would have asked I'll word it
that way Ellen White was once once asked
by her son Willie whether she had
ordinary dreams like others do that's a
good question isn't it
you know do you have regular dreams at
night no profit can have visions or they
can have dreams
a vision is typically in the daytime
and we'll see as we go on eyes open
uh you know as Ellen White's got older
the Visions became it was more dreams
and I think primarily because the
Visions were more so that people could
see there was something Supernatural to
this okay A Dream usually takes place in
your bed at night
do you have ordinary dreams mother
when she replied that she did he said
how do you know the difference how do
you know if your dream's an ordinary
dream or a supernatural Vision a vision
from God how do you know the difference
her reply quote the same Angel who
stands by my side in the vision of the
day also stands by my side in the
prophetic dream at night
now we see that in the scripture too
don't we with Daniel
the angel Gabriel comes to Daniel speaks
to Daniel he is the one that brings it
we see in Revelation chapter one God
give Jesus Christ a message to give to a
servant John through his angel
and she said so she was aware she was
aware of Supernatural communication that
was coming from the Lord let me I'm
going to skip past this a little bit how
many of you have the book here the great
second Advent movement anybody have this
book
everybody here needs to have this book
the problem one of the biggest problems
we have today is that most of us don't
know where we came from
we have no idea about our history
anymore
the great second Advent movement written
by J.N Loughborough now loftboro was our
church historian loftboro spent much of
his life traveling with the whites and
he said at one point I wondered why I
always traveled so much with Ellen and
James White until he got up in years and
he realized that God had had him in that
position so he could give eyewitness
testimony
and this is what he says in a chapter
here entitled
oops
tokens of divine guidance
this is his description of Ellen White's
condition while Envision he says before
we Trace further the thrilling account
of this wonderful manifestation of the
spirit of God I will state some facts
relative to the visions
the first time I saw Mrs E G white
formerly Miss Harmon was in October 1852
on that day I saw her in a vision that
lasted over one hour
since that time I have had the privilege
of seeing her Envision about 50 times
I have been present when Physicians have
examined her while in this state and I
esteem it a pleasure to Bear testimony
to what I have seen and know I trust a
narration of the facts in this case may
not
be carelessly cast aside for the random
supposition of those who have never seen
her in this condition he says I'm hoping
my testimony is going to Bear some
weight with you in the seeing that I was
actually there versus somebody who's
never there
in passing in division she gives three
enrapturing shouts of Glory
which Echo and re-echo the second and
especially the third fainter but more
thrilling than the first
The Voice resembling that of one quite a
distance from you
and just going out of hearing
so she started out by saying Glory
and then her voice would get fainter and
it almost sounded like even within the
person the voice was echoing like the
person was going away somewhere and you
could hard the last one was very quiet
for about four or five seconds she
seemed to drop down like a person in a
swoon like she was fainting
or having lost his strength
she then seems to be instantly filled
with superhuman strength sometimes
rising at once to her feet and walking
about the room
there are frequently movements of the
hands and arms pointing to the right or
left as her head turns all these
movements are made in a most graceful
manner
in whatever position the hand or arm may
be placed it is impossible for anyone to
move it now this was a frail little
woman
if you know Ellen White was a I think
she was about 5'4
and Wade
I think it was 95 pounds somewhere in
there very frail woman and yet during
these Visions I mean it was almost like
a zoo in some of these things they would
have people they wanted to test the
Visions they'd have positions come in
and I'm going to tell you that in a
moment and they test her physical state
you know but while she would move he
says your movements for their arms were
very graceful they would have men big
Burly men two at a time come up and try
to hold her arm still nothing would they
couldn't do anything with her as she
moved her arms so simply testifying that
you know you got this you could pick her
up and no they couldn't do anything with
her
she would move around nobody could
impede her movement
and that's basically what he's saying
here in whatever position the hand or
arm may be placed it is impossible for
anyone to move it her eyes are always
open but she does not blink
her head is raised and she's looking
upward not with a vacant stare but with
a pleasant expression only differing
from the normal and that she appears to
be looking intently at a distant object
she does not breathe yet her pulse beats
regularly
her countenance is pleasant and the
color of her face florid as in her
natural state
so in other words there's no breath but
the pulse the heart's beating and the
cheeks are flushed so she's not pale
like she hasn't been breathing for a
while she doesn't get cold
and he goes on and describes in Likens
this because any can anybody kind of
equate this to something you've read in
the scripture
if you've read Daniel chapter 10 you'll
see the same characteristics Daniel says
that my breath there was no breath in me
Daniel says I fainted when the vision
came and then the angel came and
strengthened him and you go through all
this you see the same physical
characteristics
once again the physical doesn't tell you
that it's the authentic gift of Prophecy
but it does tell you it's a supernatural
power
he goes on to give testimonials and hear
of 17 people I'm just going to share
with you a couple of them
this first one is from mg kelloggmd he's
a medical doctor as to Mrs White's
condition while Envision a few
statements from eyewitnesses may be in
place at loughborough's writing the
first is given from mg kelloggmd who
refers to the first Vision given in
Michigan May 29 1853 at a meeting held
in Tyrone Livingston County he says
quote
sister white was envisioned about 20
minutes or half an hour
as she went in division everyone present
seemed to feel the power and presence of
God and some of us did indeed feel the
spirit of God resting upon us mightily
we were engaged in prayer and social
meetings Sabbath morning at about nine
o'clock brother white my father and
sister White had prayed and I was
praying at the time
there had been no excitement no
demonstrations we did plead earnestly
with God however that he would bless the
meeting with his presence and that he
would bless the work in Michigan
as sister white gave the triumphant
shout of Glory Glory Glory which you
have heard her so often give as she goes
into bit vision
brother white arose and informed the
audience that his wife was envisioned
after stating the matter of her visions
and that she did not breathe while
Envision he invited anyone who wished to
do so to come forward and examine her
Dr Drummond a physician who was also a
first day Adventist preacher
who before he saw her Envision had
declared her Visions to be a mesmerism
and that he could give a revision
so this guy kind of said oh I could give
revision if I wanted to it's just
mesmerism
this man now is telling that this Dr
Drummond came forward and after thorough
examination turned very pale and
remarked
she doesn't breathe
I'm quite certain that she did not
breathe at the time while envisioned nor
in any of several others which she had
had when I was present the coming out of
vision was as marked as her vision as
going into it the first indication we
had that her vision was ended was in her
again beginning to breathe she Drew her
first breath deep long and full in a
manner showing that her lungs had been
entirely empty of air
after you know it makes it you know
think about it the Bible says
that the the uh all scripture is given
by inspiration of God
that word inspiration is literally what
does anybody know God breathed
she didn't have any breaths while she
was in vision
after drawing her first breath several
minutes past before she drew the second
several minutes passed before she do the
second
which filled the lungs precisely as did
the first then a pause of two minutes
and a third inhalation after which the
breathing became natural
that was his testimony signed MJ Kellogg
MD Battle Creek Michigan here's another
one
FC Castle we gave the following
statement from an individual I'll just
read you the statement from SC Castle
a physician was present and made such
examination of her as his wisdom and
learning dictated to find the cause of
the manifestation a lighted candle was
held close to her eye
close to her eyes which were wide open
not a muscle of the eye moved she didn't
blink the eye didn't move there was no
response
in some and I've read some of these
testimonies where when they'd hold this
candle up it would send your eyebrows
you know the Lord allowed that's why I
said sometimes it's almost like a zoo
but the Lord allowed people to do to
test the manifestation why because there
hadn't been opportunity yet to test the
message
and so God gave opportunity for the
people to at least know that something
was going on
no she had visions that but she usually
had them in public meeting when she had
a vision it was typically in a public
because the vision was during the
daytime and she was usually somewhere
around people
and I believe the Lord did that on
purpose but it wasn't always on Sabbath
often time on Sabbath because that's
when the saints had met together
um the candle was held not a muscle
where I moved he then examined her in
regard to her pulse and also in regard
to her breathing and there was no
respiration
the results the results was that he was
satisfied that it could not be accounted
for on natural or scientific principles
and then one more here I think this yeah
this is from a d h Lamson
this testimony he says I was then 17
years old
it seems to me I can almost hear those
thrilling shouts of Glory which she
uttered then she sank back to the floor
not falling but sinking gently and was
supported In the Arms of an attendant
two Physicians came in an old man and a
young man brother white was anxious that
they should examine sister white closely
which they did now let me ask you a
question
if this is a hoax
of all people is her husband going to
say are you medical doctor yeah would
you please examine my wife and vision I
want you to check this out and so that
we know beyond the shadow of a doubt
that it's supernatural if it was a hoax
do you think anybody would do that in
their right mind he'd be like I hope
nobody's here is there any doctors here
you know oh she's not gonna have a
vision today
it just shows us she didn't have control
over when she when she went in division
and James White would invite them come
up and check it out
okay and this is what happened uh Elder
White invites The Physician it says two
Physicians came in an old man and a
young man brother white was anxious that
they should examine sister white closely
which they did a Looking Glass was
brought they brought in a mirror and one
of them held it over her mouth while she
talked
but soon they gave this up and said she
doesn't breathe
foreign
is it possible to talk without having
any
try to talk put your hand up there it's
impossible
okay
the woman wasn't breathing for a half
hour at a time
now
and this happened I mean the cases these
are just some that he recorded here this
happened and it wasn't just
Believers these were non-believers
they're people their enemies of the face
who came in and said yeah I'll get her
out of vision just like that
that would come in and examine in fact
there was one case in here that talks of
a physician who he had boasted if she
ever comes to this town you tell me
because I'll come in and I'll bring
around a vision like that you know and
so she did she came into that town she
went in division they went across the
street this man's office said come on
over she's envisioned
so he comes over he goes up to her
and he turns completely pale white as a
sheet turns back and heads for the door
the Brethren shuts the door and they
said Doctor what's the prognosis
she doesn't breathe she doesn't breathe
let me out he couldn't get they wouldn't
let him out until he made the you know
proclamation of what he found he was
panicked and he was down the road
anyway
I'm gonna finish this one up she doesn't
breathe then they gave up uh then they
closely examined her sides as she spoke
to find some evidence of deep breathing
you know maybe she's breathing real deep
and then holding her breath
but they could not find it as they
closed this part of the examination she
arose to her feet still in Vision
holding a Bible high up turning from
passage to passage quoting correctly
although the eyes were looking upward
and away from the book now this happened
on a number of occasions
and I want to tell you that in Ellen
White's day
did not have what am I looking for what
am I looking for
something like this a nice little they
didn't have little Thin Line Bibles you
could do this with and I'll tell you
right now if you were to take this
brother and hold it up like this for a
while
you hold your hands above your head for
a while the blood runs down and and you
get tired
but in those days it was 20 pound family
Bibles that you had and this is what
Ellen White would hold in a vision this
little frail woman would sit there and
hold that Bible up okay
on more than one occasion
she had a
let me go back where I was here
turning from passage to passage quoting
correctly although the eyes were looking
upward and away from the book
she had a view of the seven last plagues
then she saw the Triumph of the Saints
and her shouts of Triumph I can seem to
hear even now to these facts I freely
testify Elder d h lambson
and uh you have a couple others from
that particular incident
somebody testified to the doctor's name
I agree with what is stated by brother
and sister lambson and would say further
that it was Dr Fleming and another
younger physician who made the
examination
said he he uh called for a lighted
candle the other testimony didn't tell
us that he held the candle as near her
lips as possible without burning and in
direct line with her breath in case she
breathed there was not the slightest
flicker of The Blaze the doctor said
then with emphasis that settles it
forever there is no breath in her body
let's take a break